welcome back to the stronger by science
fireside chat series I am as always your
host Greg Knuckles I'm not joined today
by my usual temporary guest co-host Eric
Trexler uh if you listened to the end of
our previous season you might remember
that there was an active and uh
you know relatively uh contentious
relatively violent uh Union dispute
going on between the stronger by science
podcast Union helmed by myself with with
many other members against management
helmed by uh Mr Trexler as it were
um so yeah I mean Union dispute things
got nasty uh he brought in the
pinkertons uh he he tried to lock us out
the workers in fact uh broke through the
lockout after a pretty protracted
standoff honestly a pretty protracted
Siege we had to bring in battery and
Rams trebuchets uh you know things got
things got pretty nasty but uh as I
mentioned the union one we broke through
the lines and in fact a person who was
absolutely integral to that stunning
Union victory is on the podcast with us
today so I'm joined by my comrade in
arms in worker solidarity and in
marriage uh Lindsay Ruble Lindsay
welcome to the podcast for the first
time ever hi thank you
interested that you didn't use our
shared last name uh Lindsay Lindsay
Knuckles
um that is your last name uh so yeah
welcome uh how's how's it going how's
your day
it's been okay uh
our dog recently had a bit of a health
scare spent the morning at the vet with
him spent about 400 for them to tell me
that he's completely fine and so he's
sleeping off the stress of that and I'm
recording my first ever podcast well we
are just chuffed to bits to have you
thank you
um so for the listeners if this is your
first time tuning into a fireside chat
episode uh let me just re-explain what's
going on here this is primarily a
fitness podcast but Fireside Chats are a
blessed time to have more kind of
off-topic conversation uh answer
questions from the audience about things
that aren't directly related to Fitness
and Nutrition so that's what we're going
to be doing here
um and just as in explainer about the
podcast situation generally
um so we we are hopefully towards the
back end of our c season break we
haven't put out a new episode in about
12 weeks now the the last season wrapped
up in January during that time we've
been working through some kind of
logistical stuff uh on the back end
behind the scenes that I'm not going to
go into but it's it's taking up honestly
a completely inordinate amount of time
and when we come back doing regularly
scheduled episodes we we want to make
sure that we have the time and headspace
to deliver consistently good content and
aren't just kind of slapping stuff
together to to put it out there all of
which is to say we hope and expect to be
back on a regular schedule within the
next yeah I'd say maybe two to four
weeks
um we would like to have an episode
ready to go next week maybe the week
after but yeah the the stuff I alluded
to don't want to go into details but
it's uh it's just kind of a question to
see how long that stretches out
um
and so yeah we we hope to be we hope to
be back to regular episodes on a on a
consistent schedule within the next
month and when that happens you'll be
the first to know
so Lindsay you want to you want to get
into the fireside chat questions yeah
yeah all right do you want to lead us
off or would you like me to yeah I mean
our most up
option on Reddit
the people want to know Greg what are
your thoughts on raccoons uh I have I
have many thoughts on raccoons so this
question was asked by Placid Vlad uh who
I would say probably two or three times
per week sends me very cute uh raccoon
videos on Instagram DMS them to me
um and I gotta say raccoons are
tremendous creatures they're so cute
um they the the way the way they they
grab stuff I think is is very adorable
and they
they have they have a type of
mischievous greed to them that reminds
me of like a three-year-old where you
know if they see something they want
they go after it and they're very
transfixed by it but not in a way that
that carries with it any malice so of uh
of all of the creatures on this Earth
raccoons have to be in
like the 95th percentile or above uh in
terms of General animal quality what
what do you think lens
so really love raccoons I had a lot of
raccoons on my Instagram discover which
I I say mine I mean the stronger by
science and Instagram account which I
use as my own browsing account and uh
kind of Cycles through different animals
I've had a red panda
stretch whichever we love those as well
absolutely raccoons
it's usually just dogs which are
wonderful but it's interesting sometimes
it'll it'll switch up and I'll just get
all raccoon content for a while but
they're very cute I love when they're
very chubby
yeah fat raccoons are
are great
they have you seen a video of the one
that puts some cotton candy in the water
yes and then it's very sad when it
dissolves he's so confused yeah he's so
confused
um you know what if if you have that
handy uh could you link that in the show
notes for for this yeah I'll find that
one yeah sweet uh and also something you
mentioned in that question uh that you
in fact have access to the stronger by
science Instagram account reminded me
I did a very poor job introducing you uh
thus far that's okay within the lore of
this podcast uh I'm a mysterious person
the the only thing the audience knows is
is that we're married
um and that you you also take the side
of of the workers and Union disputes of
course
um but yeah do you want to introduce
yourself uh you know share as much or as
little
pers as much or as as few uh personal
details as you want but uh what what's
your what's your relationship to
Stronger by science
alongside you we've been doing this
together since the beginning
um
I was the one who told Greg to start a
blog in college because he was talking
to me about lifting
constantly and while I enjoyed those
conversations because that's when I
started lifting as well I was like maybe
you should find some other people who
love to talk about this with you because
you want to talk about it 24 7. so yeah
gregnuckles.com was my idea yeah
honestly in a very real sense like you
are the reason that any of this exists
thank you
um
and and beyond that what is what is your
role in the business yeah yeah
try to fill in all of the gaps that you
weren't filling in of which there were
many
[Laughter]
I could have learned them too but so
what it ended up being is like I do a
lot of the management of the website and
have done most of the marketing for the
business
um so
just most of like the behind the scenes
stuff our goal was for you to be the
content person and for me to kind of be
the business and behind the scenes
person so I've done that now since the
beginning
and for the last
seven years I've also worked with James
Clear doing similar stuff marketing and
kind of like behind the scenes
management stuff
and
I don't know that's about that's about
it I guess yeah I I think that's plenty
and if uh if people want more
information about you they can uh they
cannot have it yeah they they can die
mad yeah I think that's the company line
here
um so yeah let's uh let's keep moving
along with these questions
um Jordan Gibson on Facebook wants to
know who's a better cook amongst the two
of us and I think he also requested that
we have a lasagna cook-off if there is
uh any any disagreement about the answer
to this question there's no disagreement
about the answer to this question Greg
is definitely the better cook I can
follow a recipe
but that's not exactly impressive like
that's like basic reading comprehension
and following directions and I'm proud
to say I can do that but in terms of
like actually developing new recipes and
like having a sense for what to do in
the kitchen and what is going to taste
good together
that's definitely Greg
I will say that you are definitely still
an above average cook thank you I I
think you sometimes judge yourself too
harshly in the kitchen Department I mean
in all departments honestly uh yes that
is that is true but um yeah I'm I I
think I think we both agree that I'm I'm
the better cook in the relationship
which I'm very happy with like I love to
eat more than I love to cook so this is
working out great for me you know and
honestly on the flip side I don't think
this podcast is working out great for me
so far I I forgot to invite you to
introduce yourself and the first
question I selected was inviting you to
say oh guess what you're a better cook
than I am uh honestly not not off to the
best start but I I think we can turn it
around and and so please bail me out
here by selecting a new question so we
can we can pivot as quickly as possible
but it asks us what our favorite things
are about each other
yeah
um
oh man
so yeah I can lead off
um
so I mean there there's a very long list
and it's it's hard to narrow it down but
I'm happy to review that list later if
you have it handy oh yeah yeah for sure
I'll send that over to you
um
but yeah I mean so we've been together
since
2009 right so that's like like going on
14 years
um
so I think at this point
I don't know I don't know if if these
would necessarily be my favorite things
about you but the the things that I kind
of like file as the most important
things about you that I like which which
have been crucial for maintaining a good
relationship for this long
um one I think we communicate really
well
uh two and like this this is going to
sound flippant but I think it's
absolutely critical uh you're just a fun
hang like I enjoy spending time with you
um with really no upper time cap on that
like there there there are a lot of
people I like hanging out with yeah but
you know more than four or five hours in
a single clip it's just like uh we're
not friends anymore uh please I I I
don't want to see you again for another
like week or two yeah uh but yeah I mean
we we spend all day every day together
and I I legitimately enjoy that
um
and I mean it's just kind of like a of a
kind of mushy thing you you make me feel
good
um like it's uh it it it brings me joy
to be around you so
I don't know I I feel I almost feel like
those were those were kind of like pop
song descriptions like nothing specific
like very indistinct yeah could apply to
everyone
um well we've been watching a lot of
love is blind and this is how they
describe each other on that show so yeah
maybe it's been
Slowly by reality TV
um but yeah no I mean I I think that uh
I think that for the long-term success
of a relationship
it is just very important to be able to
talk well and enjoy spending time with
the other person so
um
yeah those would be my answers yeah yeah
I mean there's a reason we decided to go
into business together and like work
from home and people ask us all the time
if we
get tired of that or like if it's hard
working with your partner and it's never
been an issue for us which is
awesome
um
so I would say the same thing I'm a very
irritable person and uh
most of the time
I find it very interesting when I have
spent like multiple days with somebody
and I'm like wow I don't like hate this
person now actually I've had a really
good time and they haven't annoyed me
the entire time like everybody annoys me
a little bit but
if somebody doesn't annoy me the entire
time I'm like okay
this is good and uh there's a very small
list of people like that and you are
definitely at the top of it but I think
that's because like you are a very easy
going person
um you're easy to get along with
and you're very kind you're the kindest
person I know you're very
good to other people and like think of
other people before yourself all right
so I'm getting pretty uncomfortable well
I just had to be uncomfortable too yeah
but but what you need to understand is I
I'm the host and so when I say it's time
to move along no I'm just you can you
can keep going I'll uh
I I can just just keep just kind of
shrinking yeah just feeling like there's
just worms wriggling around my body
wishing I wishing I was I mean I don't
want to make you feel like that because
I do like you well
so can we move on oh the last thing I'll
say is just
this is fine the last thing I'll say is
you're very funny that was the thing
that I originally like
uh really enjoyed about being around you
is you always make me laugh well I I
certainly appreciate that and and the
feeling's mutual
um great you are you are also very funny
this has been so uncomfortable yeah okay
um so embarrassing so yeah yeah we'll
we'll make a note of that we can never
talk about our feelings again yeah the
next uh so okay within the lore of this
podcast we do we do share a name which
is difficult to get around yeah well not
according to you at the beginning of
this podcast yeah you forgot that we've
been married for 10 years and that I
have a different last name now I think
we can probably be married in real life
but like maybe cousins for the for the
that is not
it can't be cousin
's friends
buddies we can just be buddies okay
all right
um yeah so so uh Switching gears
um in your answer or in uh in your kind
of back and forth about about my answer
you mentioned we'd been watching Love is
Blind which great segue into uh a
question we were asked by promotion
worth uh 2605 on Reddit and Katie
hunzinger on Facebook what are what are
some of our guilty pleasures what are
some of your guilty pleasures well first
of all I don't believe in guilty
pleasures like unless you're doing
something illegal you shouldn't be
guilty about it you shouldn't feel
guilty about it like it's fine I agree
wholeheartedly and so we've been really
into reality TV recently we've been
we're in our reality TV era and that
started with Love is Blind season three
a couple like six months ago or
something and since then we've also
watched uh what was that other Hulu
dating show about like that back in the
group yeah or something yeah about like
older women trying to get back in the
groove by dating like 20 year old men
and it was a terrible show it was it was
trash like it was so clearly and
obviously scripted yes and they weren't
great actors
um but it was still it was still fun
schlock yeah but love is blind reign
supreme in terms of dating reality shows
just because it is so Earnest all the
music choices that they have the way
that they talk about each other
it like they're just all taking it so
seriously and it's it's just very fun to
watch
um so we've done that and then after we
watched um
the White Lotus we were we were on our
little Mike White kick so then we
watched Mike White's season of Survivor
David versus Goliath and that was the
first time either of us had watched
Survivor since it was popular when we
were kids and we had a really good time
with that and we also started watching
another season of Survivor winners at
War but we didn't finish that one we
liked the David and Goliath one better
but if people have recommendations for
seasons of Survivor we are taking those
it's very overwhelming trying to figure
out which one to watch because there are
40 Seasons at this point yes
and uh then we watched The Amazing Race
season with Mike White
and
then we watched the new season which was
also not good no The Amazing Race was
not good I don't
those are just like racist at some times
yeah very racist I I don't I don't
understand
like so my the thing for me is like even
even media that I don't personally like
I can generally still
understand and like kind of get what
other people like about it yeah
um
and yeah I'm like amazing race is huge
it's a cultural Juggernaut it's been on
forever a lot of people still watch it
um
I I I just fully don't understand what
people like about that show it seems
like it's too frenetic and there's too
little focus on the individuals for you
to like form this sort of connection
with teams that you do with with uh
contestants on on Survivor for instance
um
and there's just like so much going on
in each episode that
you don't like you you always feel kind
of unmoored like you don't have a great
idea of where every team is right if one
of them takes a long time on a challenge
you don't really know what held them up
and it's just like a very capricious
game as well uh like in the season we
watched there were multiple instances of
people making what should have been like
objectively correct travel decisions and
then just like a flight randomly gets
delayed or uh like a train ride gets
canceled or something yeah and so then
they just lose which
yeah you don't like stuff like that I
don't I don't get it I don't get
Amazing Race but that's fine it's fine
yeah
but
we just watched season four of love is
blind and had a really good time with
that I feel like that's something that
people wouldn't expect about you is that
you you really love these dating reality
shows and one of my favorite moments of
this last season if if people watch this
they will know who Brett and Tiffany are
they're our favorite couple and at one
point Greg remarked if Brett and Tiffany
don't make it love is dead yes
I did say that and I I stand by that yes
um yeah no I I like
I like pure trash honestly
um
I I have I think a fairly like
intellectually demanding job yeah and
generally my brain is just toast by the
end of a work day and I don't want to I
don't want to spend my wine down time uh
engaging with media that that makes me
think about it even more yeah anybody
who says they want to do that is lying
to themselves
I I don't know I don't know if that's
the case
um
what's my hot take yeah I don't know I
just I I want something that will
facilitate my brain turning off yeah and
there there are a few things better than
reality TV for that purpose yeah yeah I
guess similarly one of my other
um quote guilty pleasures is like
celebrity gossip type media so I love
this podcast who weekly that's just all
about like Dia list celebrities and just
the wacky things that they do because
these are the people who do the craziest
like spawn con and are just out there
trying to be famous and doing the most
ridiculous things
in that Pursuit and the podcast who
weekly is just the best medium for
mainlining that content
and uh Hunter Harris's hung up
newsletter it's also very good nice uh
just just to give listeners a warning if
they if they check out who weekly you
you introduced me to it uh maybe like a
month or two ago yeah it put on an
episode while we were while we were in
the car
um I think that it might be intimidating
to new listeners yes definitely like for
I I probably so listeners of of this
podcast think that it can be confusing
due to how many inside jokes there are
my God like we I had to stop the episode
probably every five minutes because they
would make a reference to something that
was clearly meant to be a joke the other
host would laugh I'd be I'd just have to
pause it and be like what the
going on here and then you would explain
like 10 minutes of lore about where that
reference came from and be like oh okay
that makes sense yeah so I guess it
takes some time
but you know it's a rewarding process
you know you you listen to 30 episodes
and you start to get an idea of all of
the jokes and then you feel like you're
part of something bigger than yourself
yes yeah I mean in in the 1400s we had
we had the universal Catholic church and
now we have uh d-list celebrity podcast
yes yeah I mean at the end of the day
people do just want to feel like they're
a part of something bigger than
themselves and they love the gossip
absolutely yep
um well okay there was another question
here from Reddit uh by by games and
barbells uh asking what our favorite
non-fitness related podcasts are
um
you've already given one and I suspect
on your list of favorite podcasts there
probably aren't that many Fitness
podcasts showing up in the first place
zero uh are there any other
podcasts that you like and would
recommend
I think that we have a lot of overlap
um
we both really like you're wrong about
and
maintenance phase
and some political podcasts that I'm not
sure if I should mention the name
I mean why not who cares uh true and on
yeah absolutely dude when when they're
on that is one of the funniest podcasts
hilarious yeah
um also I I told I told you this but uh
I there was so for for the listeners
there's
something similar exists in other
countries but in the US there's this
like media bias
chart that goes around for like news
organizations where like the top to
bottom axis is like more credible to
less credible and then the left right
Axis is like more left-leaning like
political content or more more
right-leaning
um so the the people that put out like
the original media bias chart uh also
made one for podcasts oh my God and um
like there there weren't that many like
objectionable things in it but uh they
did put true and on there and they had
it on the left right Axis
um like near the line that said like
leans left
like
brace is a maoist like I I don't think
that's like ah Center left
um
but yeah
very funny podcast one that you don't
necessarily want to
take everything they say to Heart yeah
but entertaining and they make some good
points you know absolutely uh
so I have answered a I think this exact
question on the podcast before and I
think when I answered it previously I
said my favorite non-fitness related
podcast was knowledge fight which is
a a podcast where people are are kind of
like breaking down what Alex Jones is is
up to and getting into these days a
deranged concept for a podcast it's it
is uh it's still very entertaining it
has lost its top spot for me though
um not because the hosts uh Dan and
Jordan aren't still doing great work
they are
um but Alex Jones himself has just
gotten less interesting over time like
he's he's been stuck on the same handful
of narratives uh it's still like uh just
just anti-vax stuff
um the election was stolen from Trump
like he still owned that like three
years later
um and honestly it just seems like his
heart isn't in it anymore because he's
probably good no I mean it's a good
thing for society uh but yeah he's
currently in the process of getting just
absolutely destroyed in lawsuits and so
I think his
his uh attention is is divided
um so yeah like I think like Alex Jones
has gotten objectively less interesting
in the last couple of years so you know
you you can only polish a turd but so
much and I think I think Dan and Jordan
are doing a very admirable job of that
still but just just since the the raw
materials they're working with have
degraded I think it has lost uh its top
spot uh and so I think probably my
favorite non-fitness related podcast
these days is five to four which is a
supreme court podcast
um it is also it's it's way more
entertaining than you would think it
would be like you would think a legal
podcast would just be incredibly boring
um but it's
it's it's very engaging and very funny
what would strongly recommend
um and the person asking this question
they spelled favorite with a uh so I
suspect they're not American so uh
obviously U.S Supreme Court stuff that's
mostly relevant to an American audience
um so for something that does have more
of an international appeal I also really
like uh Q Anon Anonymous yeah which is
if if between that and true and on and
we sound like conspiracy a knowledge
fight yeah it should be clear that I
very much enjoy conspiracy theory
content
um I myself don't buy much if any of it
yeah but I think just that style of
content is
is is very interesting I think it's um I
think it's
it's neat to understand
the sorts of things people believe that
are kind of on the fringes right and
uh understanding like what leads them to
find those things that seem ridiculous
on their face like what what leads them
to find it plausible instead of
ridiculous yeah
um so yeah
those those would be my recommendations
yeah and you're a great encyclopedia for
conspiracy theories at this point now
too you always know about the hot
conspiracy theories before I do you're
extremely online uh in this one
particular Niche absolutely a subject
matter expert yes
um
do you do you have another question you
want to toss out here oh
um
what is your most underwhelming Talent
this is from pseudo Smurf on Reddit
yeah my most underwhelming talent I
would say is that I
am extremely good at slicing bread yeah
that's not underwhelming at all I'm
terrible at slicing bread and the fact
that you are good at it saves my ass
very fast very straight cuts very
uniform thickness yes
um when people say best things in sliced
bread I'm like what are you talking
about slicing bread takes 10 seconds and
you can do it just as well as machines
no most people can't they're special
it's a talent they could with practice
but I I would say I would say I'm I'm
very comfortably above average at
slicing bread and yeah that
really doesn't affect mine or anyone
else's quality of life to any any
meaningful extent so I think that
qualifies it for being an underwhelming
talent I think it impacts my quality of
life well I I certainly mostly because
when I slice the bread you bully me
relentlessly about how poorly I do yeah
you know what maybe I'm not even that
good at slicing bread and I'm just
comparing myself to you and I'm like
dude I'm I'm pretty good no I think you
I think you are really good but I'm also
I am very bad at slicing bread you're
really not that bad I just I just give
you a hard time very bad all right what
is what is your most underwhelming
Talent
um when I was considering this question
it has to be something like
organizational probably like my brain
is broken in that
all it can do is is make lists and
remind me of things that I might be
forgetting about
so
I'm very good at making a packing list
for like a trip and I'll start making
that list like three weeks before a big
trip so that I can have it exactly
Perfect by the time I'm actually putting
stuff in my suitcase I've thought
through everything I'm gonna need I've
been really strategic about all the
things I'm going to bring any
circumstance we might run into in our
travels and I'm just very prepared and I
I have my list and I'm not gonna forget
anything
you are see much like the bread slicing
thing I don't think that's an
underwhelming talent because I do not
have that at all
um I mean you know how I pack for the
audience I pack uh
that's one of the things I do in the
process of walking out the door for a
trip right which is just grab a handful
of shirts from the top of I was going to
say the top of my dresser I don't keep
my clothes in a dresser I keep them in a
laundry basket because I I wear a very
small selection of shirts I have three
identical pairs of shorts I have several
identical pairs of socks and underwear
and and that's so the shirt is the only
thing that changes day to day and uh
yeah my packing for clothes is just grab
a handful of each
um you know grab my uh my like contact
case and solution and put them in there
loose yeah yeah you just put it in there
loose yeah who cares it's fine no
smaller bags within a larger bag no
because the the material of the smaller
bag would just take up more space in the
larger bag
yeah but then you just got rattling
around in there yeah but it's fine it's
it always makes it to where it needs to
needs to go anyway it is chaotic it is
chaotic that's I I enjoy the chaos fair
enough anyway anyway so so dear listener
you get the point I just kind of grab
all of my last minute throw it in
um to the point where like
going on like a beach trip I've
forgotten to like
pack swim swim trunks before because
like those are in my closet and like I
don't go in my closet as part of the
packing process
um going overseas one time I just like
didn't even think to grab
um like a plug converter
um thankfully you remembered and grabbed
all of them yeah I basically have to be
good at packing lists so I can remember
everything you're gonna forget yes so
yeah I mean you you think your packing
is underwhelming I think my bread
slicing is underwhelming but that's
that's why we work so well yeah great we
do both have uh talents that that cover
for the other one yes
all right uh here here's a question
specifically for you
um an opportunity to brag on yourself
and flex a little bit I will certainly
not do that uh well you have to that's
that's what we're doing uh stonks 1980
asks
how long did Lindsay work with James
Clear before his book went ape Greg
what percent of the book's success is
directly related to your wife's
awesomeness
um so actually it doesn't sound like I
have to brag it sounds like you have to
brag for me because my question is
extremely straightforward I played
myself I started working with James in
2016 Summer of 2016 and atomic habits
came out fall of 2018. so a little over
two years
um and most of those two years were
spent preparing for that book to launch
and then I mean most of my jobs since
then has been related to
that book and trying to continue its
success but I mean it wasn't
I don't know I guess it didn't go ape
right away when it came out
anything like that is going to take a
while to build and
um like any product that kind of goes
viral like that you need just really
good word of mouth and a really great
product and
I was happy to be able to like help
getting get it into as many hands as
possible but you know it was the content
of the book being so amazing that made
people tell their friends and family
about it and
or like got it to sell so many copies
yeah I mean uh that that makes sense the
the one thing that I would add
is that uh Atomic habits has sold over
10 million copies now right yeah
how many books does James have that you
weren't involved in selling that also
sold over 10 million books it doesn't
have any other books
the answer is none
okay okay so uh yeah I I can just edit
this out I
actually kind of edit it out okay
how many so so Len's just a quick
follow-up question on that yeah how many
other books does James have that you
weren't involved in the marketing
process that sold over 10 million copies
none interesting
um so yeah it's it's hard to put a a
percentage of how much of the book's
success was directly related to your
awesomeness but I mean I think I think
we can all kind of surmise a general
range from from that answer
okay all right
um you're up which uh which question do
you wanna do you want us to tackle next
well somebody did ask if we
if more trolley problem discussions
do you want to do some more trolley
problem discussion I mean if you want to
have your own time
fairly frequently I would say so I've
thought through most of this okay
um very very confident let's see let's
see how long that lasts I mean it's
confident because you're not actually in
the situation
yeah that's true yeah
um all right so yeah let's just start
with with the basic one uh just for
anyone in the audience who is unaware of
trolley problems to get them up to speed
so
um there's a trolley going down the
tracks you are standing in front of a
lever if you pull the lever it will
divert uh the trolley from one set of
tracks to another set of tracks the set
of tracks the trolley is currently on uh
has five people tied to the tracks if
you don't pull the lever the trolley
will divert or if you don't pull the
lever of the trolley will keep going
straight and run over and kill those
five people if you pull the lever it
will divert it to another track on which
one person is tied so do you pull the
lever and uh and kill the one person to
save the five or do you uh draw a
categorical distinction between acts of
omission and acts of commission so which
which way do you go
I mean I think that we have similar
utilitarian philosophies and so I would
say that I would pull the lever but I
also know if I was actually in that
situation like I probably wouldn't yeah
I I'm I I disagree with the last part
but but agree with the sentiment I I
pulled the lever as well
all my homies pull the lever wow
um so okay the the point of follow-up
trolley problem questions is to kind of
probe the extent of one's utilitarianism
um so a just kind of like
the the one of the classic follow-ups is
what if the five people on the track the
the trolley is currently on
are just kind of like normal everyday
people and the person on the other track
is some sort of like
World defining genius uh who you know
has has already done a bunch of great
stuff and if they stay alive who knows
how much more great stuff they'll do
maybe a lot maybe none hard to say uh in
that case do you pull the lever I feel
like that's like Eugenics adjacent
it certainly is and so I think my answer
Remains the Same mine does as well
um but yeah that that all that that
often leads people to say I don't know
if I pull the lever on that one
um
okay uh another kind of classic
follow-up is
um to to get at do you kind of rate
just the value of lives the same or is
the amount of life left relevant so now
the five people in the track are
you know not not they don't already have
like terminal diagnoses and they're
going to kick the bucket in like two
weeks but they're they're getting up
there they don't have many good years
left uh and the person on the other
track is a perfectly healthy baby oh
a baby
a child someone who does have a
a lot of hopefully bright future ahead
of them yeah I think I saved the baby
okay
yeah maybe maybe I may just maybe I need
to examine
that internally
yeah
um yeah that one
this is probably the one that's tough
for me as well
um for for a similar reason I mean I
don't necessarily know that I would
value one year of the life of someone in
their 80s more than I value like one
year of life for someone who's like
seven right
um
but you know if we're talking about like
maybe 30 cumulative years left on one
track versus 70 on the other yeah that's
tough you know because it's there's more
years on one side but there's more
people on the other yeah um yeah and I I
honestly wouldn't feel comfortable
either way like that that one I hope you
wouldn't feel comfortable at any point
in a trolley problem Oh the the the OG
version of the problem pull the lever no
question sleep like a baby yeah
uh hopefully better than saving the baby
yeah hopefully better than the baby in
in the last one right that baby is
traumatized absolutely yeah that's you
know what maybe you maybe you pull the
lever yeah because
it's gonna deal with that trauma for the
rest of us life after being tied to the
tracks that's yeah and the old person
they might be traumatized too but they
don't have that much life left that's
and they probably have past trauma it's
like just adding on to the the trauma
it's probably nothing compared to what
they saw in nam so true honestly yeah
okay
um
let's see so
yeah here so here's a version that kind
of
gets it gets it how selfish you are oh
great and uh might
you know my might uh present a
significant roadblock not just for this
episode but for our relationship oh wow
all right I mean people on a track are a
roadblock for a trolley as well
all right five randos
tied to one track sure I'm tied to the
other do you pull the lever
I'm saving you yes definitely that is so
sweet if I'm in that situation you're
not saving me I absolutely pull the
lever
okay uh if I'm the one on the track to
be clear
you're pulling the lever to kill
yourself yeah yeah okay
well yeah I mean
what if I'm on the track uh
uh yeah I mean it's you know
sorry not sorry to the other schlubs but
right yeah yeah you're you're you're
getting out of it loyalty loyalty is a
thing yeah yeah
um
although G geez Louise the just just
knowing you the amount of like Survivor
guilt you would have after that
um oh you too I think you're a Survivor
guilt would be worse
uh I mean I was just talking about how
you're the kindest person like
I think I would have some Survivor guilt
but
you're a nicer person than I am yeah if
so okay does this change anything uh now
now there's input from the peanut
gallery I'm still tied to the track oh
my God those five people are saying lens
pull the lever and I'm on the other side
saying lens pull the lever come
on does that does that affect anything
um I think I would just get too
overwhelmed and I wouldn't be able to do
anything
laughs
that is exactly what would happen I get
too stressed out and I would just be
like no no I'm walking away yeah that's
uh I I think that's that's a very honest
and self-aware answer
um
okay do you think that's enough do we
want to I think that's enough okay cool
cool
yeah I think I think that was good and
if people want more trolley problems
like I said last time follow uh the page
trolley problem memes on Facebook
they've got some hot fire on there
um did I pick that one or did you who
who I picked that one but you were kind
of leading the discussion uh no I can I
can pick the next one uh
Sylvia on Facebook asks or says would
love to hear your experiences about uh I
would love to hear your experiences
transitioning into a tech product person
probably wasn't something you expected
what are what are your experiences on
that front
have ever worked on a product like this
so leading up to the launch of macro
Factor our app
um we were both
you know wondering is everything that
we've learned about how we sell products
about how we interact with customers is
it all going to be different with a tech
with an app
um or you know are there things that are
pretty transferable and I think we've
found that there are more things that
are the same than different but
it is certainly a different experience
like running a business like this
there's just way more that can go
wrong and it does go wrong as we have
found out
but it's exciting to have a product
that's constantly getting better and I
mean that's on the part of our
developers Corey and Rebecca who are
amazing yeah compared to say like an
ebook right you put it out you do as
good of work as you can but like when
you put it out it it is what it is yeah
yeah and you can update it but that's
going to be like a multi-year process
probably whereas like with an app like
we are releasing new updates new
features multiple times per year and so
the product is constantly evolving you
constantly have new things to talk about
on my side doing the marketing like
we're constantly kind of reassessing our
strategy and how we talk about the
product and figuring out what people
find the most interesting about the
product so it's just a lot more Dynamic
and that has been really exciting and
fun and also very very stressful yeah
uh on my side
honestly
honestly the changes have been more
more a matter of degree rather than a
matter of kind like I don't think
I don't think the stuff I'm doing is all
that different from what I was doing
before but there are two big differences
one is in just kind of like General time
allocation yeah
um
so this is and I I don't necessarily
think this is specific to
um the fact that it's a tech product I
think it's
relevant to the fact that like this is
just a like like already a like bigger
business than what we had before yeah
um bigger than anything we've ever done
yes and so there has just been a lot
more kind of like logistical
administrative tasks and work yeah uh
than before which
is you know that's that's not
necessarily my favorite thing to do yeah
I I definitely prefer the content side
of things to the kind of like back into
business side of things so there has
been a change in kind of like time
allocation where there is just more of
that stuff to do now
um and on the content side there has
definitely been a shift as well where
I'm still making a lot of content but
previously
um
previously I could generally work with
the assumption that the content I was
making was for kind of a a core audience
that has
already consumed a lot of my content and
knows knows where I'm at on things and
also is just kind of like nerdy people
like yeah I don't the the the median
Fitness content consumer isn't a
stronger by science reader right like if
you find yourself consistently consuming
our content
um yeah the the type of stuff you're
into is different than the than the
media and fitness content consumer
um
but and so you know for like website
articles I'd be like hey you know I'm
I'm writing to nerds so like I can just
leave leave some things not explicitly
stated like there will be kind of a
shared set of assumptions and
understandings that people yeah that
people bring to content
um and you know I I can refer more
heavily to like things I've written
previously that I know a pretty good
chunk of people will have read
um
and with macro Factor like I I am making
a lot of content for it but it's our
first product that has like seriously
broke containment yeah where most of the
people using the app aren't people who
are from kind of the core stronger by
science audience
um and so it's it's almost been like
returning to my roots where I'm writing
with the assumption that most of the
people reading what I write don't know
who I am don't aren't particularly
acquainted with
uh a good chunk of Stronger by science
content so things need to be kind of
phrased in more simple language a lot of
things that I could have just left is
kind of like unstated assumptions and
background information do have to be
explicitly laid out
um so yeah it it has definitely changed
how I need to approach the content I
make yeah but do you like that like do
you find that exciting
I find it to be a
interesting challenge for now yeah
um
yeah I mean we'll we'll see we'll see
like there there are there are parts of
it that are very boring so like I I
recently like revamped the the macro
Factor knowledge base and like a pretty
good chunk of that is just kind of like
technical writing right like hey here's
how you create a recipe or whatever
um
the kind of like more informative
explanatory content I honestly do
I I do really enjoy
writing kind of like simpler stuff that
is going to be
more understandable to a broader
audience yeah
um and I don't know if that's something
that is generally true and will continue
to be true forever or if it's just like
hey I was kind of doing one style of
content almost exclusively for a decade
and now here's just something else but
for for the time being I'm really
enjoying it yeah
um
but yeah I mean honestly
just to just to Circle back not that
much has changed I mean day to day I'm
doing administrative stuff I'm doing
content stuff and I'm interacting with
the audience that is still what I'm
doing that is what I've been doing up to
this point but the type of content has
changed and the kind of balance of
content tasks to administrative tasks
has has shifted as well yeah it hasn't
been like a huge huge difference yeah I
think it makes a difference that like it
had it did start as kind of a small
Pro like a small company kind of thing
you know like we were bootstrapping this
we didn't get Venture Capital funding or
anything like that like we treated it
like a regular product that we would
have launched
um instead of it being like a completely
different animal and we started with you
know just launching to the stronger by
science audience and then have kind of
expanded out from there and are just now
kind of getting into
the place where we're having to figure
out like okay what does this actually
look like to grow huge Way Beyond
the people that we're used to talking to
yeah it's been
um it's definitely been an adjustment
but I'd say overall it's been very fun
oh definitely
all right uh we have one more kind of
normal question and then we have one
pre-selected that we were going to end
with yes
um so the final one from Facebook is
what is your favorite exercise scene in
a movie or TV show
mine is definitely
the scene in Mulan where the the Make a
Man Out of You song and the training
montage
it's I mean I don't really have that
much to say about it other than it's
very cool and the song is a banger and
when my sisters and I would watch that
growing up we'd get all fired up and
like pretend to be doing karate and
on each other
and anything that like really fires up a
kid is is good oh absolutely that that
song that song is one of one of the
biggest Bops in the Disney Canon for
sure
um mine also a great karaoke song by the
way do you want to do it right now no
okay
I figured it didn't hurt to ask uh mine
you you gave me about this before
we started recording it is probably the
most cliched answer to this question yes
um but it's the training montage in
Rocky IV
um
it's I mean it's
a classic uh favorite training montage
in cinema for a reason it's great the
the song is excellent Hearts on Fire
really really gets me going
um no I mean it's it's a it's like what
the Mulan song did to me it's like it
makes you want to get up and start
punching things yeah it's a great 80s
Jam
um the training montage itself is sick
just so many cool shots him him running
up uh that hell no that's that's uh Kate
Bush yeah yeah that's a different media
franchise
um but that would have been a great song
for that scene though when he's like
running along the Mountain Crest oh okay
so I have never actually seen that movie
all I know is that he runs up those
stairs in Philadelphia that is Rocky one
oh my God yeah so I'm not even thinking
of the right thing yeah so every I think
every Rocky movie has a training montage
that makes sense um yeah and the two
most iconic shots are him like running
up the stairs in in Philadelphia in
Rocky one and just the entire Rocky IV
training montage but yeah so running
along the kind of snow-capped mountain
range very cool yeah Lord of the Rings
Vibes yeah he's doing some resistance
training with uh just like a a just
detached trailer that I think he loads
up with wood that's also very cool
um he's kind of like training in a barn
and so he he's doing like fully upside
down sit-ups which I thought were just
just incredible at the time I also did
you try to do it uh yeah yeah did it
work yeah yeah it's it's not as hard as
it looks like oh okay uh but it looks
very cool for the camera
um
and then if memory serves Rocky IV is
also the training montage where he does
um like really really strict Dragon
Flags oh my gosh yeah those are very
impressive yeah very cool so yeah it's
it's got to be the training montage in
Rocky for also
in in honorable mention in the Rocky
franchise which goes under discussed is
so like everyone knows Rocky one through
four are are excellent movies Rocky five
not so much you kind of kind of seemed
like it killed the franchise and then oh
I don't know maybe like 2012 or so they
tried to reboot it with Rocky Balboa uh
the the last Rocky film where Stallone
himself is is the main character
um which wasn't as bad as Rocky 5
certainly wasn't as good as the first
four
um didn't do well enough to justify more
Stallone Rocky movies which is why then
they diverted and said hey let's let's
go to the Creed route
um so yeah that the Rocky Balboa is a
relatively forgettable film for the most
part but it also has a great training
montage
um and I I think I say that as a power
lifter because kind of the whole the
whole thing of that training montage is
uh Rocky Balboa himself is older so he
doesn't have the endurance he once did
uh he's not as fast as he wants as he
once was
um by every conceivable metric the fight
that he's about to go into he should get
his ass kicked because he's fighting a
young hungry skilled heavyweight boxer
um that should just wipe the floor with
him and so his whole strategy going into
the fight is well at least I have the
puncher's chance like if I can throw
just nasty enough punches he can be a
better boxer he can have better lungs
than me he can move around better than
me but as long as I have that one punch
power I just need to clip him with one
just right and I can win which that is
very powerlifting adjacent yeah yeah
just like but what do you squat it's
awesome so so yeah the whole training
montage uh I think I think the line that
kicks it off is uh you've got to throw
hurt and bombs and then immediately it
cuts to him like squatting 500 pounds
and just like doing a bunch of heavy
weight training
um so yeah I I also really enjoy the
training montage in in Rocky Balboa
you know maybe you've convinced me to
watch these movies uh you know so I mean
honestly no no like this this is my
recommendation to both you and the
audience okay I haven't seen the Creed
films I've heard I've heard they're good
yeah
um I do yeah I want to watch those we
should watch the first four rocky films
okay we can skip Rocky five it's not
good we can find the training montage
from Rocky Balboa on YouTube we don't
need to watch that whole movie sounds
good but yeah then and then we can go
into the Creed films I I think I think
that would be good it's a plan sick
all right our final question yeah I can
read this one out yeah look go for it so
this Reddit username is Hot Tomato Sauce
69. nice nice hell yeah and the question
is if you could have one animal as a
sidekick that could communicate fluently
with you and would help you with
anything you ask
which animal would you pick and then
there's a parenthetical they live as
long as you do and share your level of
intelligence
yeah so I I wonder if the person who
asked this question
um
watched uh His Dark Materials yes or
that's immediately what came to mind
yeah or or read those books yeah because
yeah this sounds like the the demons in
in those stories
um
but yeah I I would probably go for
an animal that could like fully
exploit uh some sort of like movement
option that I don't have access to which
God damn it now I'm just making it sound
like a video game
um but yeah I mean like I I can't fly I
can't uh hold my breath underwater for
like a super long time and I can't fit
into tight spaces
um I mean there's a finite amount of
space tightness that I can of course I
can deal with I you know I have a
particular volume you certainly do
so yeah just right away I either want
something that flies uh an aquatic
creature or something that can that
that's much smaller than me yeah you can
fit into really tight spaces
and I think I would probably go with
probably go with some sort of relatively
small bird
um
I was thinking maybe a bat but they
don't they don't have a great vision and
I think like for being able to go up in
the air like that that would be good for
just like getting the lay of the land
right
um
and you know like bats are small they
can go in tight spaces but like a small
bird could as well how small because
like aren't crows and ravens very smart
like they can remember people's faces
and stuff too well this question
presupposes that whatever we choose
whatever level of intelligence
um yeah I mean if if this if that
stipulation wasn't there yeah um like a
like a raven would be pretty high up on
the list honestly
um but I'd probably go with some sort of
primate uh where that stipulation uh not
there right
um but yeah I probably go with a small
bird I think
um although because I I don't spend that
much time around water or get into that
many aquatic hijinks if I but you could
if you had an animal friend I mean I
can't breathe underwater still you know
yeah that's not gonna happen for you
yeah so my my number two would probably
be an octopus because they they have the
Aquatic thing and the fitting into tight
spaces thing uh but yeah I probably go
with a small bird of some sort
how about you
so this might be a cheating answer
because I'm going to talk about
something that's not real so we recently
played a Pokemon game
in which one of your Pokemon that you
get very early on in the game is
basically an all-terrain vehicle
and the Pokemon can you can ride it like
a motorcycle
um it can climb up Cliffs it can fly and
it turns into like a speedboat on the
water and it can jump really high and it
can jump really high yeah
so yeah that's what I'm choosing
all right sure
um
so let me uh let me let me hit you with
an option here okay
um it's not it's not going to get you
the flight but I think it might be able
to serve your your needs for the other
ones
and also relates to his dark materials
what about a polar bear that was my
first thought honestly yeah like when I
read this question I immediately thought
of his dark materials and then I
immediately thought of the really cool
polar bear yeah and uh yeah just having
like a war bear that's really smart and
that you can communicate with that would
be awesome absolutely
um
I also think
I don't know so this
so this says like the animal would share
your level of intelligence but it
doesn't say that it would have like the
exact same type of intelligence right
um
just the same general level
and so I wonder if
I wonder if it would make sense to
choose an animal that would have like
very specific insights that if you
scaled up that type of animal's level of
intelligence to like human level would
be like super sick so for instance or
like an ant that can like communicate
with a whole yeah like a host of other
ants yeah so uh I I was thinking like
ants or like bees or something yeah yeah
which might understand like complex
social interaction on a level that like
humans wouldn't have the same sort of
innate feel for or
um
like a like a cat maybe which um just
like yeah like most most animals but
like specifically felines just just have
like such a ridiculous innate
kinesthetic sense like they they might
kind of just understand the spatial
world around us so much better than I
would that you know they're they're even
if we have the same general level of
intelligence there would still be kind
of like unique insights of that animal's
type of intelligence that that I
wouldn't be able to to come to on my own
um you are allergic to cats though that
could be an issue yeah but I'm so uh uh
several people asked just kind of like
allergy related questions
um and it's worth noting I'm currently
getting allergy shots uh this is this
has been
I think like objectively in terms of
like pollen counts a very rough allergy
season and I'm not that far into my
allergy shots yet but it's it's been
notably better than prior years for me
so
I don't yet feel confident exposing
myself to a cat in in kind of a long
duration type of deal in a sidekick
situation yeah yeah but
um yeah I mean give it give it another
year or two you never know you never
know
sounds good all right
um well let's let's wrap it up there uh
thanks everyone for listening
um like I said at the top of the show we
will be back with regular episodes
coming out more consistently relatively
soon uh aiming for the next two to four
weeks and uh we will keep you posted on
that front uh thanks again for listening
hope you enjoyed it and uh
talk to you again soon bye